welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for the lord of the rings the
rings of power series dropping on prime
video on september 2nd now normally we
focus on marvel in star wars here on
this channel but back when i started we
were mostly a game of thrones channel
and uh don't worry we have not forgotten
about house of the dragon we're gonna
get on that soon i honestly don't know
how we're gonna cover all this [ __ ] in a
month but uh we'll find a way and for
those of you who don't know what this
series is i'm gonna break down this
trailer to explain how it really
connects to tolkien's novels and what
you remember from peter jackson's films
and how this show will hopefully be more
than some hobbit predecessors with itchy
hats let's get started there was a time
when the world was so young
[Music]
there had not yet been a sunrise
but even then
there was light the trailer opens with
the line there was a time when the world
was so young there had not been a
sunrise but even then there was light
now the lord of the rings in a hobbit
were set during the third age of middle
earth this series is set during the
second age the events leading up to that
prologue that we saw in the fellowship
of the ring the forging of the rings of
power the rise and the defeat to sauron
and the failure of men when a sealed
urge told elrond to [ __ ] off now tolkien
cemetery recounts the events of the
first age when the evil morgoth was
driven from middle earth into the void
and sauron went into hiding this series
will explore sauron's return in the
second age and his rise to power in a
secret creation of the one ring to rule
the other 19 that were divided amongst
the elves the dwarves and men so amazon
secured the rights from the tolkien
estate for specific parts of this
history from tolkien's appendices to the
lord of the rings books as well as other
supporting works and case-by-case parts
of the cimarillion history all this
first age era which this show will flash
back to now j.r.r tolkien fought in the
first world war and his son christopher
fought in the second world war and
that's when jr wrote much of the lord of
the rings text christopher later on
edited much of his father's posthumous
work and even drew the original maps for
the books so lord of the rings has
really always been a story of an older
generation passing down knowledge to a
younger generation and each contributing
chapters to that overall narrative we
saw this with bilbo and frodo in lord of
the rings frodo completing there and
back again a hobbit's tale and returned
to king and now elder figures like
elrond sharing the narrative with
galadriel and in a way these three ages
of middle-earth parallel tolkien's own
era a past era that was stricken with
war the return of the threat and even
more brutal form in the third age but
now this period in between when everyone
missed the warning signs this opening
shot shows the numenorean vessel sailing
through a canyon with faces carved into
the cliff walls now numenor was an
island kingdom that once existed but
sank into the sea in the conflicts and
geographic destruction that ended the
second age humanoids were an important
part of that force that brought down
sauron but much of their history and
culture remains lesser known so the show
has a bit more creative freedom to
explore it this particular location
might be the vignelonde later londo
dayer the great haven which plays a
major role as the numenoreans help the
elves and ariador fight sauron's forces
during that second age the closest
statue to the city gate that we see
might be valomo lord of the waters and
now we see the great elven city of
tyrion beside the two trees of valinor
one gold lauraleen and one silver
telparyon these were literally the
source of the light in the land of allar
and seeing them here means that we are
flashing back to the first age because
they got destroyed at the end of the
first stage by melkor and the primal
spider ungoliant and their last flower
and fruit were transformed by the velar
into the sun in the moon galadriel was
the elf played by kate blanchette in the
peter jackson films here a younger
version of herself played by morgan
clark when galadriel was more of a
warrior elrod of course is a half elf
lord of rivendell played by hugo weaving
in the jackson films here played by
robert romeo i love this detail the
music in opening seconds samples howard
shore's rivendell theme from the peter
jackson films
[Music]
let's move
[Music]
else have on to protect
dwarf their minds
mend their fields of grain here we see
more of the beautiful landscape
photography of new zealand aka middle
earth including an expedition of elves
across the snowy mountain range now on
the map there is a northern waste north
of the ford wave that little is known
about delatrio could be leading a group
in search of sauron then we visit the
dwarf city of kaza doom in moria this is
the location where the fellowship later
makes camp when it is in ruins but here
it is thriving leafy vegetation growing
from the ceiling some sightings of
agriculture in the lower right corner
bridge is far more intact than the one
gandalf will later fight the balrog on
and in the upper left you can see two
dwarves operating some machinery to
redirect this beam of light across the
cavern presumably to help these plants
grow and make this cave beneath the
misty mountains so habitable these beams
were actually referenced in tolkien's
book frodo wakes up to see a beam of
light entering that 21st hall where they
were camping from windows on the east
side of the mountain it's just another
example of how light in this world is a
precious resource carefully harnessed by
beans like the elves and the dwarves to
maximize their effect and their use not
taken for granted since these races are
old enough to remember the two trees
being destroyed sometimes worrying about
the fate of these characters can get you
so stressed out you just want to pull
your hair out but if you are the kind of
guy worried about losing your hair in
the more natural unfortunate way well
our friends at keeps can help you out
because two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 with
keeps you can get quality expert care
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or a pharmacy keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss products out there but at half
the cost of your local pharmacy though
you never have to go into a doctor's
office keeps has a network of expert
medical advisors prescribers and care
specialists who support you in making
your hair goals a reality easily
subscribe to keeps and get refill
reminders so you'll never run low on the
products you need to take care of your
hair hair loss stops with keeps to get
50 off your first order go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash new rockstars moving on but we our
foots have each other
[Music]
we're safe
so here we meet the heart foots which
are the genealogical predecessors to the
hobbit race alongside the stores and the
fallouts all three groups mentioned by
tolkien and his concerning hobbit's
fellowship prologue this hard foot uses
a whistle to signal to the others about
the approaching antler men and despite
their beliefs in being safe one hardfoot
nori sees a meteor crash land nearby
we're gonna talk a lot about that later
but let's move on you have fought long
enough galadriel
put up your sword
the enemy is still out there
the question now is where
so el aranda tells galadriel to put up
your sword which could be a quote
alluding to the bible john 18 verse 11.
then jesus said to peter put up your
sword into the sheath the cup which my
father has given me shall i not drink it
jesus was telling his disciple peter to
not bother fighting the roman soldiers
who had come to arrest him that really
jesus's fate was sealed and this is part
of his father's plan for him making this
a kind of ironic thing for elrond to
tell galadriel galadriel is trying to
hunt down sauron and eliminate this
threat forever but elrond perhaps
knowing that evil is always going to
exist in the world and there's really
not much they can do about it galadriel
leads a group to explore an ice skate as
the hand of a snow troll moves in the
foreground creepy on to the next clip
it is over you have not seen what i've
seen i have seen my share
you have not seen
what i have seen here this overhead shot
of a city along a river i'm guessing
this is numenorean and then now around
and galadriel debate how much they have
seen really both of these characters
have witnessed horrors from the
conflicts in the first age and suffered
personal losses as their family members
were killed but i think aladrilla is
referring to a future vision she has
seen a premonition of the fall of
numenor in the return of sauron now
perhaps the most eye-catching shot of
this trailer is this image of dead
soldiers floating in the water as
overhead a tower burns some are
suggesting this could be the sinking of
numenor but i don't know this first
season would just be really early for
that others have wondered if this could
be the war of wrath the final of the war
of the jewels fought over the cimarrial
gems that were crafted by the elves from
the two trees this history of course
explored in a cimarillion this is a war
between the balar and morgoth where the
northwestern region of middle earth
belarian was shattered and sunk into the
ocean as well this was the end of the
first stage but actually here we are
seeing the first kinsling at aqualond
the haven of swans in which feanor
leading the noldoran elves attacked the
talaria elves to steal their ships this
will be why we're seeing elf corpses
impaled by elf spears moving on
darkness will march over the face of the
earth
it will be the end not just of our
people
but all
peoples
[Music]
[Applause]
so the vessel arrives in the harbor of
noubenor created by the statue of aaron
diehl father to elrond and to elrose who
was the first king of numenor now others
have pointed out how this statue design
recalls the look of the argonaut and
peter jackson's films whereas ariane
deal has an open palm to greet visitors
the argonath held their palms out as if
to turn people away showing how humans
over the ages went from open-minded and
numenor in the second age to close off
in gondor during the third age then we
meet gil galad lord of ariador and high
king of the elves of the west gilgalad
led the combined forces of the elves and
the dwarves and the men that we saw in
the fellowship prologue and spoiler
warning in case you considered texts
published for decades spoilers for the
show you're about to watch tolkien wrote
how gal galad confronted sauron and just
sauron's hand to his face caused him to
burst into flame but that along with the
human ellen deal sacrifice gave isildur
the opening he needed to sever the
finger from his hand and i like how here
gil galad seems properly concerned about
the concerning threat as opposed to like
completely naive and blind to it now
there's some really interesting parallel
shot composition in this section we see
elves in a swan ship as birds float
around them then tarmurial the queen
regent of numenor reacting to petals
floating around her and then the heart
boats as embers are floating around them
all these floating objects could
represent doom facing these characters
really doom coming from the embers of
the crashed meteorite now in muriel's
case these petals could come from a
white tree in numenor as it senses the
danger remember how peter jackson
established the white tree in minnesota
which actually stayed dead in the source
material but in the film it butted a
flower when it says aragorn's return i
just think that the focus on the two
trees could imbue just a greater
importance to the health of all of these
trees as a symbol of sauron's presence
or absence and we get our out-of-focus
shot of our meteor man played by daniel
weyman credited for now only as a
stranger but i think we can all assume
probably a form of sauron more on that
in a bit let's move on
i am sorry
but their time has come
[Music]
the past is with us all
the past is dead so elrond visits khazat
doom and here we meet the dwarf king
during the third as well as his son
during the four who smashes a boulder
the kind of move gimli was going for
when he tried to smash the ring in
rivendell and then what looks like the
numenor throne room we meet a new
character named hal brand and the fact
that we don't know much about this guy
makes me wonder if he could grow up to
be someone important perhaps one of the
nine kings who are entrusted with the
ring the future witch king of angmar
lord of the nazghul we see him fighting
in the storm that could lead to a
shipwreck and it sounds like elijah will
also go through a shipwreck in the
series there's a quick shot of aaron
dear the sylvan elf who seems to get
captured by orcs but breaks free and
pulls off some insane acrobatics on the
show he's gonna be part of a forbidden
love affair subplot his chest blade
seems to show the face of an ant that's
fun we are a voice saying the past is
with us all i believe that to be the
voice of isildur talking to his father
both of whom we see in the next section
we either move forward
or we die with it
this could be the beginning of a new era
yes so this bearded man is ellen deal
father two isildur the leader who later
joins gil galad in the fight against
sauron that we see in the fellowship
prologue while we don't really see gil
galad's fiery death in that scene we do
see ellen deal get thrown and killed by
sauron in a sealed door running over to
mourn him before sauron stomps over to
attack and a silder uses a broken blade
to sever the finger but also isildur is
depicted here as just this numenorean
sailor years away from that moral
corruption the ring will curse him with
now yes men are not supposed to live
that long but this show's producers have
said that they're going to be doing some
time compression on this series next we
see arvarazun before a cheering crowd
and numenor this is as he prepares to
steal the throne from his cousin muriel
i think we can expect numenor to be the
source of the game of thrones style
political intrigue of the series during
the fourth holds a piece of mithril this
is in its raw mineral form of course the
material that's later used to make the
chain mail armor that bilbo gives frodo
and then there's this shot of elves in a
circle drawing swords perhaps part of
the oath of thanore in which the sons of
theodore vow to find the cimarrials
after the two trees are destroyed this
would make this another first age
flashback and then back to the stranger
in the meteor crater pieces of debris
float and notice how the fire sucks
inward toward him suggesting that
there's some sorcery behind this arrival
and the whole thing may be some trickery
because notice how the overhead shot
makes the fire in the shape of a ring
but also an eye both of which seem to be
pretty solid clues pointing to this
being sauron because if we come back to
the christian symbolism here the fact
that this guy falls from the heavens
does remind us a bit of lucifer the
fallen angel sauron was known to be a
shape-shifter and i think this is part
of his plot to pretend to be an emissary
from amman but some from the heavens
however since true emissaries from amman
are supposed to come from the sea that
could be why galadriel and gilgalada do
not trust this guy overall this series
seems to show how all of these societies
will be fooled into forging those 19
rings of power blind into the one ring
forged in secret by sauron and it could
be a lot of fun to watch that corruption
in the form of this false prophet who
used political machinations and
religious fanaticism to turn these
factions against each other i just hope
that the show can do it in a way that
makes these civilizations still
interesting and smart and not overly
blind or oblivious to the evil but
rather following the normal course of
human nature or i guess dwarf and elf
nature blind by their own ambitions or
their paranoia or their tunnel vision
there's just lots of ways that you can
make people blind to evil without making
them stupid or obtuse i have high hopes
for this series though thank you for
joining me for this breakdown you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eabot so you can follow me rockstars and
you can subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you